so amber I'm going to start with you
obviously as the writer producer
director of you have a lot to tell us I
think about the origins of this piece
what I know from the notes here is that
your friend
Amy's Poehler handed you a book and
there began a tail yeah I am about I
must spend 10 years ago and he said you
know there's this book I read over the
summer it's amazing but with no I think
I towards adapting it at all just like
as a friend saying hey you should read
this book it's really beautiful and I
think she thought that I would really
respond to the sort of Pope being a poet
myself respond to the sort of poetic
prose a narrative in the book which I
did and I had I had read books before
that felt like they could you know live
somewhere in in a cinematic world but
this for some reason just got under my
skin the book did and I couldn't get it
out of my head and I think you know once
I started down the road of pursuing it I
couldn't I just couldn't let it go
so we originally thinking of it to act
in or I was yeah I had I had originally
if you see that there's in the thank
yous Ben Foster is in there and so
originally I'd written it for Ben Foster
and I could be in and the Michael role
was a little bit larger and and so that
was sort of where it started in my early
20s and as most films take a very long
time to get made I got older and felt
that there would be a real difference
between someone who was in their early
20s compared to someone who was in their
late 20s or even early 30s the way that
I am and I felt like that the character
really needed to be to have a naivete
about her and that could only come from
youth so when did the decision to direct
happen or and when did you decide that
that's what we wanted to do this is your
first directorial effort yes yes my
first film I you know it came late in
the process I had for a couple years
been shopping it around and had a
wonderful producer Ren Arthur that I was
working with and was looking for
directors and it just sort of seemed to
be that every
we spoke to they had they had a vision
of the film that they wanted to make but
but it bumped up against the vision I
had for the movie and and it was finally
it was actually Courtney Hunt who was
attached to it for about a year and she
and I sat and sort of I did a couple
rewrites for her and she you know she
had a very strong vision for what she
wanted to do with the film but
fundamentally we disagreed on on many
different aspects one of the biggest
ones was a funeral scene what she really
wanted to be this like nasty handheld
you know a gnarly fight between two
women and I really didn't see it that
way I saw it on bordering on comedic and
arch and it was Courtney who said to me
you know I think you're missing the
greater point here which is that you
clearly have a strong vision for the
movie you want to make and you should
make it to which I was like oh no no I
I've never you know I don't have any no
experience and and she's like you think
half of men who make films have any
experience at all that's a good point so
I just uh I jumped in the cinematography
the production design the editing the
music the look of the film let's talk
first about the look the lighting of
this film seems almost like it's a
specific character being added could you
talk about the discussions you had about
what your palette was going to be for
this film well I think you just said
that it was deliberate storytelling and
amber being so clear and direct about
what her scenes were about what her
characters are about when her stories
about really we didn't have much time
and there was so much economy and
everything that we were doing that we
were trying to be as direct and visual
as possible to get across what what the
seams about the stories about and you
were so clear about it that I'm excited
that people feel that because I felt
that there was a real pressure of
getting things done with like a like a
poverty certificate circumstances and
most economical way possible so it's
nice to see that everything did achieve
the emotional response we're looking for
how many also original way I'm 21 21
I mean arraigned anyone else no less and
this is only half of what we shot I mean
this movie actually starred Alfred
Molina and Russ Tamblyn and I cut them
out of the film like a lot by the way
no I let's talk about that a little bit
what Alfred's part and and Alfred also
talked about you know what what maybe
what the part was as you saw it when
you're shooting and then what you see it
on the screen what was the transition
for you as an actor to see the way that
character was dealt with by this by the
director well it was it was a
combination of things what one was that
I just love making films like this you
know independent films small films I
think it's where people find themselves
at their most creative creativity that
comes out of a sense of necessity there
isn't you know we don't have the luxury
of time or money or resources so you
find people are really working and
really working very creative very very
ingeniously to kind of get things done
I've known amber for some time she and
her dad came to see me in a play many
many years ago and we had the we had the
same reps for a while and so it was I
was very pleased to get involved in her
first film and I've admired her as a
writer and as an actor and I thought
this you know if she's a triple threat I
won't get in on the action you know but
it was it was also the script was really
interesting and I and III thought it was
so such a refreshing change to see a
story to see a script that was driven by
two female characters for a start which
is to me much much more interesting in
terms of the dynamics of a story a
female director and I just thought this
is this could be really really
interesting
and I like the roll I liked the part I
liked this father who in a sense had
failed and was trying to somehow make
amends even though it was a bit too late
perhaps and--but after the fact and I
found that very touching and and and
also and as amber alluded to the the the
scene that the scene that made me laugh
out loud and made me think oh yeah I'm
going to do this was the funeral
which had this wonderful kind of
farcical element with you know the
mother and the girlfriend come out
struggling to get and and the father
yeah it was just that there was
something I'd never seen that before I'd
never I'd never experienced that in a
movie before and I just thought it was
they just they just felt really you know
sometimes with a bit of script I don't
know if they're any actors out here but
I don't know but sometimes with a script
you can kind of smell a good story
there's something about not just the
things people say but the things they
don't say the moments in between the
lines and that just kind of really rang
out to me I just really clean two gigs
you know really excited to get involved
so Russ I am I mistaken there's like on
a shot that is there is but I mean for
real
this movie is 96 minutes long but when
we did the first assemble of it it was
three hours and 15 minutes so almost
half of the footage you know ended up on
the cutting room floor and some of red
stuff and and certainly my dad had come
in and done this really lovely scene
with Janet and you only see him for a
quick moment and I tried everything I
could to keep that scene in there but it
just I mean that was those were areas
where you started to feel like we need
to keep pushing towards this ping-pong
match between these two women and
everything else just sort of has to
suddenly a different movie yeah a little
bit but I think I would have I think it
would have been sacrilege to not have
Russ Tamblyn in my first film I would
have been cruel so I kept so I kept
appease and I still have he told a
really great story I think to Janet
because I said just tell I want you to
tell her a story in this scene so we
ended up doing that so I still
that and you'll play it out it's like a
short film just dad and you know the
directors car the directors got there it
is yep it is I can see the DVD now
yeah extras oh well I actually of course
I'm in crew amber wouldn't be here for
one to me there but I noticed I was
thinking to watch it at this time I said
about the fifth time that I've seen the
film and I particularly noticed the
influences that when that she was
brought up with as a as a child being
around David Lynch and and especially I
was thinking about a movie that I made
called a haunting and the haunting was
about two women that that of Julie
Harris and Claire Bloom who had a really
strange kind of relationship and but
house the other thing about the haunting
was the house was a really was a big
character and I really noticed this time
more than any other times that I've seen
it how much of the house had a way
bigger part than I did it specific but
it was important I mean because the
house was really a major character in
the film and by the way as far as for
directing I don't even know if you
remember amber but ever used to direct
we had little cameras remember we went
to Colorado and she used to make movies
and she was always directing she was
directing all the kids in the
neighborhood you know do this do that
thank you all for being here thank you
thank you very sorry about the film
thank you